بعد ساعات فقط مما
تقول السلطات الأوكرانية إنه غارة روسية مميتة
على هذا المبنى السكني،
بدأ الناس العاديون بالفعل في العمل بجد في عملية
التنظيف، لا توجد دموع هنا،
لا توجد شكاوى على الرغم من
مقتل شخص واحد على الأقل وإصابة عدة أشخاص
عندما انفجر.  لقد سقطت على
الأرض ونزل الدم من
جبهتي، أخبرني سيمون البالغ من العمر 76 عامًا لكنني
كنت محظوظًا بأن هاتين الشظيتين
أصابتا الحائط وأخطأتا رأسي،
إنها ببساطة جزء من الحياة في هذه
المدينة الواقعة في شرق أوكرانيا.  على بعد
حوالي 25 كيلومترًا (حوالي 15 ميلًا)
من خط أمامي نشط للغاية
وكان كروماتورسك هدفًا متكررًا
للصواريخ والصواريخ الروسية القاتلة،
حطم الانفجار جميع
النوافذ تقريبًا عبر الفناء من
نقطة التأثير الرئيسية هنا في روضة الأطفال
رقم 49. يمكنك  أرى أن هناك
الكثير من المتطوعين والعديد من
معلمي المدارس الذين يعملون هنا بجد في
تنظيف الشحنة الزجاجية ووضع
الخشب الرقائقي الذي تبرعت به
الإدارة هنا
أخبرتني مديرة المدرسة أنها تقول إنها
سقطت على الأرض  بسبب قوة
الانفجار هذا الصباح، ولحسن
الحظ، لم يكن هناك أطفال في
هذه المدرسة عندما وقع هذا الانفجار.
يقول المدير إن
المدرسة مغلقة بشكل أساسي منذ حوالي
ستة أشهر، وأنه
تم إجلاء جميع الأطفال إلى أماكن أكثر أمانًا
حتى الآن  تذكير قاتم آخر بالمخاطر
الرهيبة التي
يعيشها الناس كل يوم هنا
في شرق أوكرانيا إيفان واتسون سي إن إن
كروماتورسك أوكرانيا